[Music]  people judge you hear nothing and you  are - here you hang out with  so you're gonna ask Roxie out again are  you just gonna spank one out to every  day till graduation if it makes my life  a little easier and I do I have to do it  I'm out of here  remember one thing though you have my  sloppy seconds telling you man one day  they're gonna go too far and I'm sorry  [Music]  I have to tell you something there's  something that said it wants to kill me  are you kidding me norm I swear to god  there's something is on you all right  and show me let me see your pet monster  dude don't you see what this means  we can use this as his power  what nobody's ever gonna mess with us  again you crazy  think about it it's not murder its  payback it's not a gift or a weapon  distinguish what they did to me this  what the hell is happening damos inside  that [ __ ] get in  watch your digestion  you